[Música]
vamos a la revista de prensa con Rosa
Pérez más déu Rosa Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela terminábamos el
noticiero con la noticia del periodista
del Wall Street journal que fue detenido
en Rusia y usted nos tiene la ampliación
sobre lo que dicen los medios
internacionales de este tema exactamente
Ángela y precisamente los hemos fijado
en el comunicado que ha sacado el propio
Wall Street journal porque como decíamos
Iván Girls quien hace la reportero que
trabajaba en la corresponsalía de Moscú
de este medio estadounidense fue
detenido en las pasadas horas No se
conoce exactamente cuándo pero sí que es
acusado por parte de las autoridades
rusas de espionaje concretamente de
obtener información clasificada sobre
las actividades de una de las empresas
del complejo militar Industrial según
las autoridades rusas que supone un
secreto de estado bien la detención la
llevó a cabo el servicio secreto ruso el
fsb Y tuvo lugar en la ciudad de
yekateringsburg esto es en los urales
rusos bien el Wall Street journal señala
que básicamente niega vehementemente
estas acusaciones de espionaje por parte
de su periodista por el que le podrían
caer 20 años de prisión y rechaza no las
alegaciones que han lanzado desde Moscú
además varios medios internacionales
destacan que se trata de el primer
periodista estadounidense en trabajar
para un medio estadounidense que es
detenido y acusado de espionaje en Rusia
desde la Guerra Fría sin embargo entre
todo este contexto no podemos obviar que
recordemos el australiano también
Juliana Sánchez está acusado de
espionaje El Sí en Estados Unidos por el
que le podrían caer Bueno más de 150
años de prisión a también si finalmente
es extraditado ese país Bueno pues este
es una estrategia que se utiliza por
occidente y por oriente por igual de
forma Rosa pero aquí preocupa el tema de
la Guerra de Ucrania no y de
recuperarnos del caso de Britney y ya
estamos otra vez con un estadounidense
en problemas diplomáticos con Estados
Unidos exactamente es lo que señalan no
que están tomando Bueno es lo que señala
Estados Unidos que Rusia estaría tomando
como rehén a este periodista a cambio de
algo que por lo menos de momento todavía
no ha expresado pero lo sabremos pronto
Rosa Vamos a continuar en Estados Unidos
no es ninguna sorpresa los congresistas
se reconocen una vez más que harán poco
para cambiar las legislación sobre las
armas esto es vergonzoso bueno pues sí
Ángela y así lo señala usa today que
dice parece que el último tiroteo masivo
en la nación la masacre de este lunes en
una escuela cristiana en Nashville
Tennessee puede convertirse en una
historia familiar llamados a más control
de armas seguidos de inacción política
destacan también la posición de Joe
donde el presidente estadounidense que
dice que él ha agotado todos sus
recursos desde el poder ejecutivo y
señala que ahora mismo la pelota está en
el campo legislativo tanto como
activistas como la mayoría de los
demócratas piden una una prohibición de
concretamente los rifles de asalto una
prohibición como la que tuvo lugar entre
1994 y 2004 sin embargo el año pasado
los demócratas intentaron impulsar esta
prohibición que quedó finalmente
bloqueada en el senado no biden atrás
está masacre lanzó la pregunta por qué
permitimos las armas de guerra en
nuestras calles y en nuestras escuelas
Bueno pero es que uno se pregunta para
qué necesita uno en una casa un rifle de
asalto y se pronunció también sobre esto
el Washington exactamente que vuelve a
destacar que esta arma está diseñada
para la guerra y pide explícitamente la
prohibición de los rifles de asalto dice
los ataques siempre son dolorosos pero
son cada vez menos sorprendentes tanto
las masacres como las armas que se usan
y además nos da una cifra Y es que 10 de
los 17 tiroteos masivos más mortales
perpetrados en Estados Unidos en la
última década fueron con un AR 15 no con
este rifle de asalto y nos ha dado
algunos ejemplos que Lamentablemente
todos guardamos en la memoria como
ubalde Las Vegas o parkland no Además
otra cifra uno de cada 20
estadounidenses Ángela tiene al menos un
ar15 no esos son 16 millones rifles de
asalto circulando por Estados Unidos en
manos de civiles cuando recordemos es un
arma de guerra acaba señalando el
Washington post El ar-15 se ha
convertido en un símbolo cultural Pero
qué clase de cultura tolera la muerte
tras la muerte de 10 27 y 49 o 60
personas el respeto por la segunda
enmienda no implica quedarse de brazos
cruzados mientras los niños de 6 años
son hechos pedazos
No tengo más palabras para hablar de ese
tema rosa así que le voy a pedir que
cambiemos y nos mudamos hasta Colombia y
aquí uno se pregunta si hay que separar
al artista de su obra como mínimo el
caricaturista matador muy conocido en
ese país fue suspendido y luego
despedido por el periódico El Tiempo
donde trabajaba después de que se
conociera que hace una década agredió a
la que era su esposa exactamente y esta
información a como tú bien dices hace
referencia a unos hechos que tuvieron
lugar hace una década pero que se
conocieron estos días debido a una
disputa entre el abogado de matador
Julio César González quinceno y el
propio matador no que tuviera que tuvo
lugar en las redes sociales y en que el
abogado acabó revelando que el
caricaturista de este medio del tiempo
fue denunciado por su mujer hace 10 años
y detenido por las autoridades por una
agresión Pues de género no una agresión
contra su mujer al conocerse esta
información o al menos al hacerse
pública no sabemos si el tiempo
la conocía De antemano o no Ellos dicen
que no este medio colombiano pues acabó
suspendiendo a la caricaturista no en el
comunicado que emitió el tiempo señalan
que
rechazan tajantemente cualquier tipo de
maltrato contra una mujer y que de
acuerdo con su campaña no es hora de
callar y con los principios de su línea
editorial la dirección del periódico
pidió a matador que se pronuncia sobre
los hechos no y que mientras tanto
suspendía su participación en el medio
bien hay muchos medios de comunicación
que se han hecho eco no de esta
situación aquí en Colombia como el medio
feminista volcánicas que celebra la
decisión y pidió que esta suspensión
Ojalá fuera definitiva como al parecer
finalmente es el caso no Además
volcánicas dicen el humor misógino
racista y transfóbico de matador había
sido señalado en múltiples ocasiones por
activistas y organizaciones Defensores
de Derechos Humanos Por último el
espectador también de aquí de Colombia
destacó la respuesta del propio
caricaturista al medio el tiempo vía
Twitter no con un tono total de
despedida en que el alego que se trató
de un error personal que cometió y
enmendó no Pues sí pero de todas maneras
Tienen que llegar las consecuencias en
algún momento Rosa gracias a usted y nos
vemos mañana hasta mañana